on va faire une interview hockey mineur
sa vue kevina salut ça va
ça te dérange pas si je te tutoie kevin
ah non c'est vrai ça quasiment l'âge de
mon grand-père
que l'humain je sais que tu as une
grosse poitrine pour ton âge y songe oui
je fais un choix sensé
il se fait quel âge maintenant balle à
10 ans dans quatre ans je rêve un an
way présent
aucune classe
science n 2 parce que j'ai redoublé
trois fois le c2c mes parents
considèrent que je suis trop mûrs
et écoute quoi comme musique en ce
moment qu'est bien à un rv à 10 ans je
télécharge tout sur internet alors je
sais pas trop
et dix mois kevin était allé voir mes
z'amis concernées justin timberlake à
paris
j'ai une copine qui était alors gistré
tout le concert son téléphone que ce
qu'elle a un forfait neo
tu veux faire quoi plus tard kevin à
ouchy pas j'aimerais bien être une star
c'est possible mag a dit
[ __ ] quelle est la politique et bina
away jeu disons je pense que l'année
prochaine je veux très pur
pour nicolas royal et ségolène ségolène
sarkozy je suis pas
tu t'entends bien avec tes vieux
western s'engagent moins sanguin avec ma
mère mais mon beau père c'est un connard
heavy semoun tu aimes bien il s'est
nourri à wes j'aime bien j'aime bien son
hymne aux chaînes bien disons pour moi
c'est meilleur comique de ces
générations
ce qu'il aime bien beau et trop beau il
ressemble alain delon et en plus vieux
et tu crois que sans ces lentilles
bleues ils auraient fait la même
carrière franck dubosc non je connais
moi bah ouais il est toujours avec
cadres à changer de mains qu'avec icade
avait annoncé
avec m
[Applaudissements]
il t'a amené jean et on jules pour la
saint-valentin kevina à wells on a été
dans ce restaurant américain mc do
vous embrasser sur la bouche avec ton
mec ou non non c'est juste des snacks
mais pas la langue ah non juste avec mon
chien
vous avez jamais couché ensemble en fait
non je couche qu'avec mes peluche pour
l'instant
et ça fait quoi d'apprendre que britney
spears était maman kevin anin oui
qu'est ce tu fais après l'émission
kédina ben je rentre chez moi je peux
pourquoi tu as quelque chose à me
proposer une soirée aux parents ah ouais
super
j'adore la grande bourgeoisie
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux